it should not really be a surprise that
con artist and now convicted felon jesse
smilet was found guilty of committing a
race hoax the evidence against him was
overwhelming
you know they say that absence of
evidence is not evidence of absence but
in the case of a hate crime hoax that's
often not true if smollett was really
accosted and assaulted by a roaming gang
of militant bleach-wielding white
supremacists there would have been lots
of positive evidence to support that
claim the fact that there was no such
evidence was reason enough to conclude
that the claim was a fabrication that
along with the fact that the story was
absurd and implausible and ludicrous on
its face on every level
except in this case there was not only
absence of evidence to support his
version of events but positive evidence
disproving it since his co-conspirators
admitted their role in the plot and
produced documentation to show that
there was a plot
all of this to say
there should not have been any suspense
a guilty verdict should have been a
foregone conclusion but as the jury
failed to reach a verdict somehow on the
first day of deliberation and the hours
ticked by during the second day
it started to seem quite possible that
they would maybe come back with an
acquittal
justice smallett's defense team
certainly didn't do anything to convince
them of his innocence but
they played the victim card constantly
reminding the jury that smilet is a gay
black man that indeed was their whole
defense that he's a gay black man
um the victim card shouldn't be worth
anything at all especially in court and
especially when it's played by a wealthy
actor but in our country today it can
unlock many doors
and get you out of many jams
and it could well have done that here
yet it didn't the justice system
actually worked and not for the first
time in recent weeks it's on a little
bit of a of a streak i guess
and jesse smallett was convicted on five
out of six counts yesterday he faces up
to 20 years in prison
and should serve every day of it
although i expect he'll probably just be
given a slap on the wrist a few hours of
community service and we'll get back to
this issue of the appropriate punishment
for his crime in just a moment but first
it's worth recalling
what the left said about the smollette
case when the story was first reported
by a credulous media
now when i say the left i mean not just
random accounts on twitter but the most
prominent and powerful individuals in
that camp
joe biden at the time tweeted what
happened today to jesse smollett must
never be tolerated in this country we
must stand up and demand that we no
longer give this hate safe harbor that
homophobia and racism have no place on
our streets or in our hearts
we are with you jesse
notice there's no alleged
no words like claim or reportedly being
used
just an outright acceptance of the story
in its entirety without a hint of
skepticism
same for camilla harris who said at the
time
josie smolet is one of the kindest most
gentle human beings i know
i'm praying for his quick recovery
this was an attempted modern day
lynching
no one should have to fear for their
life because of their sexuality or color
of their skin we must confront this hate
an attempted modern day lynching
it wasn't much of an attempt considering
the assailants gently placed the rope
around his neck and then ran away 30
seconds later according to him
so that's like trying to shoot somebody
by throwing the bullet at their head
but that kind of critical thinking is
not allowed when a member of a protected
class makes a claim of this sort
which is why every major leftist in the
country rallied around jesse
the daily mail takes us farther down
memory lane they report
going back to 2019
other liberal stars whose pro-jesse
tweets have now aged very poorly include
democratic representatives and squad
members alexandria caser cortez as well
as rashida toled
aoc at the time tweeted there is no such
thing as racially charged this attack
was not possibly homophobic it was a
racist and homophobic attack
if you don't like what if you don't like
what is happening to our country then
work to change it it is no one's job to
water down or sugarcoat the rise of hate
crimes
and then talib said when one of the most
famous black and gay men in america is
not safe
the message is clearer than it's ever
been
uh the dangerous lies spewing from the
right wing is killing and hurting our
people thinking of you justice millet
and my lgbtq neighbors
other top democrats who rallied against
the now debunked beating include house
speaker nancy pelosi in vermont senator
uh bernie sanders pelosi soapboxed the
racist homophobic attack on justice
millet is an affront to our humanity no
one should be attacked for who they are
or whom they love
she's right though
no one should
and thankfully no one was
but out of all the famous leftists who
used the smellet hoax as an opportunity
to prove their woke bonafides
none could top ellen page who
back when she was ellen page went on
stephen colbert's late night show and
tearfully blamed mike pence
for the fact that jesse smallett
attacked himself
now in retrospect
not even retrospect but even at the time
this is maybe the funniest segment
stephen colbert has ever aired and it
was unintentionally funny let's uh let's
go back and watch a little bit of this
again
i'm like really fired up tonight this is
how this is how you have to be fired it
feels impossible to not feel this way
right now with the president and the
vice president mike pence who like
wishes i couldn't be married let's just
be clear
the vice president of america wishes i
didn't have the love with my wife
he wanted to ban that in indiana
he believes in conversion therapy
[Music]
he has hurt lgbtq people so badly as the
government of indiana and i think the
thing we need to know and i hope my show
gaycation did this
in terms of connecting the dots in terms
of what happened the other day to josie
i don't know him personally i saw i send
all of my love
connect the dots
this is what happens
if you are in a position of power and
you hate people
and you want to cause suffering to them
you go through the trouble you spend
your career trying to cause suffering
what do you think is going to happen
kids are going to be abused and they're
going to kill themselves and people are
going to be beaten on the street
i have traveled the world and i have met
the most marginalized people you can
meet
i am lucky to have this time and the
privilege to say this
this needs to stop
so powerful so sincere i mean she
literally sounds like she's reading a
script
she's met the the most marginalized
people
like you know hollywood actors
very marginalized
how does this work by the way because
ellen page is a man now she says so her
relationship with her wife is actually a
heterosexual marriage
you know however however that works i
don't know
we know um that ellen page
was a privileged white male mansplaining
about the jessie smilet case
and of course everything she said was
wrong listen if you want the title of
best-selling children's author i can't
help you with that i mean you got to
write your own children's book uh but
here's another title that you can have
all to yourself very easily you could be
a lord or a lady established titles is
your opportunity to earn the title of
lord or lady and gain the respect you
deserve i am also a lord lord best
selling children's author matt walsh
all you need is a one square foot plot
of land in scotland established titles
is a project based on a historic
scottish custom where landowners are
referred to as lairds or lords and
ladies in english in your title pack
you'll receive at least one square foot
of dedicated land on a private estate
and an official certificate with a crest
and uh usually this this certificate
with in the past has been in a frame but
that was
given to um michael knowles and it was
never given back to me so
i guess when in our lordship i guess we
see how the hierarchy works there your
certificate will include a unique plot
number with uh with which you can see
the exact location of your land with
this certificate you could officially
change your name to a lord or lady and
get it on your credit card your plane
tickets etc establish titles is having a
great limited time sale so go to
establishtitles.com
matt walsh to save ten percent off today
and remember to use discount code matt
walsh or just click the link below
that's established titles dot com slash
matt walsh or just click the link below
what we have to understand about ellen
page and joe biden and camilla harris
and all the rest of them is that they
all of course knew that the hoax was a
hoax at least they knew that it very
well may have been
but in their minds even if it wasn't
true
it was still true on some deeper more
ambiguous level
you know if jesse smilet wasn't a victim
of two white guys in in maga hats in
chicago at 2 a.m in january he was still
a victim in general as far as they were
concerned
not only that but but he was by virtue
of his identity a victim of white guys
and baga hats
none of them have to actually attack him
or
do anything to him or even say anything
to him
to victimize him
they victimize him by existing and he is
victimized and he is victimized by
existing
this is the tortured thought process of
a leftist
and it's how they justify elevating and
amplifying and demanding that we believe
every race hoax that has ever been
concocted
because even if it's not true it's still
true
what was that phrase from uh
from alexandria case or cortez
you know something could be factually
wrong but morally correct or something
like that
that's how they look at it
they've decided ahead of time who the
villains are and who the heroes are
the details of any individual case are
irrelevant
and even if it ends up not being true
technically speaking by amplify
amplifying it they still succeed in
reinforcing their victim narrative and
driving a wedge between the races which
is their true intention
that's also why going back to jesse's
punishment
um
in a truly just country
i know i said our justice system is
working but
maybe we could say in these few cases
it's worked as well as we can expect
but if it really worked
justice millett ought to be charged with
a hate crime himself
know just like we if you if you falsely
claim that someone raped you
and it's proven that it was a false
claim
then you should get the penalty that
they would have gotten had they been
convicted based on your false claims
and so if you if you claim a hate crime
and it didn't happen
then you should be charged with a hate
crime yourself
now the hate crime category is
intentionally
vague and arbitrary and shouldn't exist
now you could argue that almost all
crime is motivated by hate on some level
or most of it
or worse by indifference
i mean who's to say that crimes driven
by hate are worse than crimes driven by
indifference to human life most school
shootings fall into this latter category
maybe not so much hate as just total
indifference to human life
much of the violence that we see in our
cities is is motivated by total
indifference to human life
is that is that is that better than
being motivated by hate
and who's to say which sort of hate is
worse than other kinds of hate
the whole category again should not
exist but since it does
it ought to be used here against justice
millet
because we should be clear about what
this was
it was not just a hoax or a scam and it
was both of those things
but it was also an anti-white hate crime
now remember hate crimes do not need to
be targeted at any individual single
person so if you hang a noose on a tree
as a threat to black people in general
you'll be charged with a hate crime of
course as it happens every new sun a
tree story ends up being a hoax or
somebody misinterpreted a tire swing or
something
but if ever there is a real case if that
ever actually happens
it will be a hate crime
and be charged that way even if there is
no one specific individual victim
so justice millett's hoax was an attack
on white people
in general white conservatives
especially
it was meant to stir up hatred and
resentment towards that group he had
other motivations as well
you know this was this was a also a ploy
in contract negotiations
as it turns out you know maybe the worst
contract negotiating technique ever
employed by anybody
but on top of that he had ideological
and and other kinds of motivations
and one of them was
anti-white
it was meant to reinforce the worst
stereotypes about white people white men
white conservatives
and i have no doubt you know that if if
two random white saps had made the
unfortunate mistake of walking somewhere
nearby on that night in chicago
and the police suspected them of the
crime because they happened to be caught
on security cameras walking nearby or
something smallett would have had no
problem
sending them to prison for 40 years to
pay for a crime that he made up
i have no doubt about that
that's the other thing about about a
hoax hate crime
is that you're you're throwing this out
there
this grenade you're pulling the pin on
the grenade and throwing it out there
and uh if it explodes and takes some
innocent person out
that's that's your fault and you
apparently have no problem with that
that's why you're doing it
so if there was if there was real
justice in in this country
you know if someone had actually done
that to justice
millet uh and it wasn't his nigerian
friends
but if there were two if if that story
somehow in some bizarro world was true
what what penalty would those
attackers be facing i'm thinking 40 to
50 years in prison probably if not more
that's what justice malek should do
[Music]
because this was a hate crime
uh itself
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated